what are the positives has this changed
because i
i keep looking for silver linings has
there been anything that's changed your
perspective during this quarantine
where you think okay i didn't think
about that before but
now now my perspective is different uh
maybe the
maybe the internet and twitter and being
online isn't the be-all end-all
like what if this what if the quarantine
is is
the version of you catch your kid
smoking so you make him
smoke a carton of cigarettes we've all
been online so much
but i almost when the quarantine lifts
there's going to be a crazy shift away
and just i just want to be outside
actually looking at people
actually embracing stuff and and the
tactile world
wow what if that's an actual thing
that's going to happen
wouldn't it be a weird backlash against
like all the
being online because of being stuck
inside
i think there will be i think it will
last about four hours
everyone's gonna go outside and touch
trees and breathe
air and touch each other and and go to
restaurants for about four hours and
then everyone's gonna go back
to these things and they'll all do
instagram stories about being outside
and not being on
the internet wow yeah and then
well yeah and then on the other hand
uh i've gotten way too into watching way
too many
movies and t and and it what you really
what you find out very quickly is
all of the really good stuff that's on
netflix and hulu
and canopy and uh shutter and all these
channels
um you go through the good stuff pretty
quickly and then you start
searching for the the weirdest like
i'm actually craving bad films so like
i've been watching
steven seagal movies and if anyone
there's a lot of
later steven seagal movies on netflix
he's the ones that he makes where
he just does not get up out of his chair
in the movie
it's so amazing and if there's any
steven seagal movies the later ones on
netflix
watch them with closed captioning turn
the subtitles on because these poor
closed captioners
stephen said only we don't have a lot of
dialogue so there's a lot of like
thrilling music explosions and then when
steven's on screen
it's um effort standing up
as he sits heavy breathing heavier
breathing
squeezing um you know like there's just
a lot of they will articulate how badly
he's doing physically is there actually
a closed captioning that says
aging badly
you know i was thinking about it fresh
from craft service
um you uh you are a victim of this
because
uh you did in your stand-up special i
love everything
someone found this and they put it out
there and i think you've been spreading
it around too
they took a freeze frame of the closed
captioning that accompanied you
on stage and it
says uh rambles comma
groans let's take a look at that right
now there it is this is an actual closed
captioning for you
rambo's comma groans
why that because closed captioners or i
know people that have worked close
captioning a lot of them
are struggling writers struggling
performers they've got to try to make
that job interesting
so they will slip in little moments of
poetry whenever they can
and that's a that's a gorgeous moment
rambles comma groans
that will that will be the title of my
next
special that's perfect perfect and it's
so
what this time is right now that is if
there are two words to describe
2020 it's rambles comma groans
[Laughter]
you know i was trying to dis and we just
we we start rambling angrily and then we
just sort of pause and then we just kind
of give up and
and the other person isn't offended by
that they're just like yeah exactly
yes yeah awful
you